we're social beings were wired to
connect with other people and when human
contact is withdrawn it can have a
serious impact on physical and mental
health
that's especially so for patients
confined to hospitals strict visitor
policies are in place to limit the
spread of coab in nineteen so some
hospitals have developed creative ways
to keep patients in touch with their
loved ones especially seniors who don't
have the technology to do it themselves
when Toronto Area Hospital allowed us to
see how its virtual family visit program
works
it was March 20th so that's when the
hospital instituted their limited family
presence policy at the hospital at that
point we sort of mobilized large group
of colleagues throughout the hospital to
create the program my name is Sarah
Carney I work as the elder life
specialist here at the North York
General and I've been redeployed to work
as a facilitator in the virtual family
visits program when they come in and
couple days later which I was very very
shocked I miss my favorite.i I know I
[Music]
change my mind we started thinking of
other things I think about him about
that soccer game in the scale of 10 I
put 9 plus we're gonna call Ileana ok
[Music]
[Applause]
even just seeing smile on their face at
the patient's face light up as soon as
they see their family members has been
[Music]
[Music]
our senior population rates of delirium
and functional decline are quite high
and families are really integral in
helping those patients not to develop
delirium or other problems in hospital
my name is Shawna Haberman I'm the
patient and family-centered care
consultant for North York General
Hospital I was asked to act as the lead
on our virtual family visit program the
full donation was 100 iPads 50 of those
iPads have been earmarked for our
general site and 50 iPads have been
earmarked for our seniors health center
which is our long-term care facility
it's just over 600 patients who can
benefit like I've been living a
nightmare since the middle of March he
tested positive and he had had a fever
and he wasn't really responsive
it was terrible like it was so scary I
thought I was in tears thankfully he
didn't have any respiratory problems and
in a few days he came around we talked
every day many times a day
and I live for that you can't go on life
without seeing somebody you know or
communicating the phone isn't enough
okay so good you're so alert right now
amazing
you're the best you're a tough lady
absolutely and everybody loves you all
the time she was loving and generous to
all of us like my mom and all that our
moms are no longer life she is the only
thing they have thank you the baby on
cream
ever since I've started in this new role
I just find it so meaningful I find
myself thinking about these maybe it's
part of the family connection piece but
even when I'm not at work and thinking
about the patients here how they're
doing and thinking about their family
members one special lady I love her
[Music]